[Music]
in killin with kindness news submitted
by Steve green I'm sorry never any
noodles of noodles an Austrian athlete
was freed by her kidnapper after
complimenting his orchids really mm-hmm
that's been some nice organs or nice
compliments or a dumb ass thief or a
weak man maybe that was his love
language and the orchid was the symbol
yeah oh all right so this story took
place in Austria and this triathlon Tory
the athletes like a triathlete cyclist
champion her name is is Natalie and
she's 27 years old she has a baby at
home in case you're wondering so she's a
mother who got kidnapped and forced into
a van after being hit in the head with a
big-ass dick and they try to like use
her for sex slaves
turns out it was this 33 year old man
that did all this and so um so she's
saying that she was beat up blindfolded
and forced at knifepoint to drink some
alcohol some schnapps and this man is it
I've never done shops is nice yeah
sweetie so maybe they thought what kind
of alcohol to get her to so like they're
like I don't get her Jager like get
something like we have a green apple or
something maybe yeah so this is just
just one man by the way mm-hmm damn we
did this and so when she woke up after
getting hit with a stick she said that
she woke up naked Oh into a chair in my
old house yeah and she said her left
forearm was broken it was broken there
was the biggest it I got she got whacked
with yeah she got beat with it not just
like one whack you got yeah yeah don't
even use a 2x4 over there cuz I go by
centimeters I think so it could be she
got wet the stick point five by five
point three and she's a athlete yes a
cyclist champion she looks good she was
training she was on her bike oh well
they just whacked the wall she was
riding her bike yeah so then this red
van like on this road and then this red
van drove up to her
that's a station wagon that's actually
scary that happens a lot too here in Los
Angeles you had to be really careful
with the construction bins that's
happened like in mahalo when I used to
live up in that area that they would
follow the girls that were hiking and
there there were stories of them being
kidnapped the same type of way mm-hmm I
don't know what happened
oh he's obsessed at the sec I know my
job because no like remember that movie
the taken the hostel hostel Oh taken is
the one yeah Liam Neeson hostel is when
they killed while alert all right yeah
so then use this big-ass dick Jesus like
a [ __ ] staff dude they didn't have a
tape measure like they had to tape all
the rulers together folded wow like it
can be folded anyway so this is a big
got the actual stick yeah for evidence
man so as she was in this house right
she couldn't see that big-ass dick
coming I thought it was a shorter came
from behind
think he's driving up on the station
wagon and whacking her from the side
like yeah she's probably scared as [ __ ]
that's high not drive her like that Josh
did oh he just did her with a car yeah
but she's holding the [ __ ] station is
dropping into that well could they drive
all the [ __ ] right side that's why
you could hold it out like this that's a
good point right there driving like this
yeah they [ __ ] hit her like a giass
it or ass go to pieces already how do
you drive and whack someone because it's
hard or whack if you're right-handed
just doing this [ __ ] you gotta go like
this wow that I love the backscratcher
in your hand entire story that was a
mill the [ __ ] skin flake said he just
it was like meant to be this story in
you in the back scrub there's no it
doesn't say that he just admitted of
course well she could have said it so
anyway so then so her falling off the
bike also [ __ ] her up you [ __ ]
idiot why'd you put this [ __ ] in my head
what happened nothing
you're stupid they have a stupid idiot
come along that's two I think I should
get wet everyone [ __ ] laugh alright
they saw that shake sure I think I'm
just in a dark place right now okay I'm
sorry
you should join us in the light I wish I
wish I'm trying man I'm trying you get
through Advent I tried I thought it
we're not there at the dark place yet
just happen just it hurt right let's we
know what's gonna happen but okay let's
just laugh at the jousting so anyway
moving off from the jousting okay now we
can be sad
so back inside the house where she's
naked and tied up and her [ __ ] her
you [ __ ] raped her dude so okay well
you don't know she might have got away
by the right thing because we keep going
back to that moment it's she did not get
raped because she did get a medical exam
after how would she know cuz she was
sleeping
I just told she was examined but you
could tell for sure cuz what if he
didn't bust a nut
skin flick yeah or leaker why was she
thank you cuz he probably was prepping
her oh I could tell you what happened so
he brought her over to a bathtub full of
cold water and then had her go in there
and he kept dunking her head in there
like trying to drown her oh he forced
her mouth and nose shut and tried to
suffocate her and with these towels that
he'd like threw in her face and then so
he was just like manhandling her a lot
and then well he sucks at killing she's
not dead but then like she's like oh
your orchids like in between all that
yeah let me tell you the rest so then
she ended up at one point you're missing
the Golden Nugget jokes though that was
funny didn't hear it
bright cuz I'm so focused on telling you
guys arrest what was it he said you
should just suck SEC he sucks at killing
but you had a baby I mean like he's
trying so hard the Golden Nugget what
turned out to be this whole situation is
that after she started talking so she
noticed all these beautiful orchids
everyone she knows how much work it
takes into their beautiful
anything [ __ ] you like orchids -
holy Sh
[Laughter]
what if she's a real stickler about her
orchids and he's like in when she wakes
up in the chair he's like what do you
think my orchids is she's like they're
not very well I know how long it takes
to treat them I get it yeah what if
she's like I'll Water them for you what
have you like dried at her ed like teach
me how you [ __ ] fix your orchids all
right teacher hi people the lives and
then she's on the news later and they're
like what like what what was your
thinking that moment she's like I had to
lie about the orchids to keep myself
alive that was a great saying though is
that once she complimented him on his
orchids he started to be completely nice
to her like his whole demeanor changed
and he started telling her how he was a
gardener and that he had such a messed
up life where his dad had died his
mother had become an alcoholic and his
girlfriend had cheated on him and so she
ended up making a suggestion saying like
hey how about we just say this was this
was an accident
like you accidentally like something
happened with me riding my bike and you
brought me to your house it helped take
care of me and fix my bike and we can
just call it a day because she was
saying that she's a mom as well like she
wants to take care of a 14 week old baby
baby yeah he's a he's a dad no no or he
lost his parent he lost his dad and the
mom was alcoholic and so he was just
saying like he was just pouring out his
his shitty life to her she's so
manipulative
she showed some empathy and so that's
when her because she said like you could
tell that this guy needed was like a
friend in his life history he was just
so like trying to control her and you
could
that he didn't really know what to do
with her but he was threatening to kill
her and it just seemed like he kind of
just lost it that's his way of dealing
with all this anger like he had dude
that was a failure in everything I mean
kind of negotiation though look at that
so then he ended up agreeing and he
drove her so she said first he drove her
to this he dropped her off too so he was
yeah but I fixed her bike and then I
took cuz they had to get the story
straight
right I was all an accident so then
that's what he fixed the bike and then
he was driving her to her house but then
he was like oh hold on let me show you
this empty plot of land that was given
to me about my family and then so she
started thinking like [ __ ] am I gonna
have to make a run for it like what if
he's gonna kill me at that empty bottle
in but then he ended up just staying
there for a little bit and then like
being silent show-and-tell
isn't that cool he's a damaged person
imagine all the orchids like a [ __ ]
crowd here so then he ended up taking
her to her front door and hello Sam he
knows where she lives
bite me up so then immediately we're
friends now right immediately when she
got home because her partner was
watching the baby and then we're not
searching for her she never came home
and so they finally when she got home
she called the police and she let them
know what happened and they used the
tracking thing from her site the GPS
data from her bicycle to locate his
house expensive ass bikes hmm she was
married her friend now he's all like
that [ __ ] I shouldn't apply [ __ ] it
just yelled her yeah like she's the real
shady one she's she was such a liar they
had an agreement jokes aside though man
like she's [ __ ] blast oh yeah she's
bad face I've that's unheard of no no
just the boy is a genius yeah I know
he's so lucky that she was vigilant and
was looking you know everywhere
yeah that's always recommended for
getting drowned - keep your eyes open
yeah noted damn cuz if what if it was
like [ __ ] they should even care about
like big trees or something do or
whatever what if the organs weren't
healthy and she's like man what's wrong
with orchids and then he's like I can
only wait he had her for six to seven
hours that's crazy I was like that's odd
that's a lesser torture session that's
Christ I was she was just think she was
trying to find a way to be empathetic
with the guy so God anything and you're
just trying to like connect with him on
a human level
that's how hostage negotiators and like
suicide negotiators like that's the they
find a connection that's why if you're
out there trying to kill somebody do not
connect people that's right don't let
them reach you yeah I mean there's
always the advice for the person trying
to run away from the killer right
[Music]